he's the only artist we've ever met with
who was like actually social hacking and
get on Instagram and then he's doing
cool things with the fans like when put
me on to where he's like he told all the
kids are yo play my new song over the
intercom in your school and I'll feature
you there getting suspended from that's
what's up
so if he did that and he's doing hacking
like what you were talking about with
dunk then you're gonna win because you
have actual music talent that I already
know and then the only other part that
matters is distribution and you you are
naturally it comes natural to you to
hack distribution I always talk about
the example of P Diddy going on TRL
or when I wear Christmas sweaters
courtside at basketball games it's just
understanding what's gonna get you hurt
the end yeah it's only two things is it
good enough and what people [ __ ] hear
it straight up that's good man the retro
brands they're saying you know what you
owe you [ __ ] you know what's amazing
about you youngsters you guys are coming
with so much more entrepreneurial savvy
than the crew that came before you
everybody's trying to be a mogul out
here it's cool it's good man that's
that's how you really win dollars are
more interesting than cents and
everybody was settling for cents you
know everybody was settling settling for
cents and then puff and jay-z and
Birdman those guys deserve a lot of
credit they started quite a framework so
good makes me happy man good for you
that's what's up yeah man anything I can
help you with yeah I know I know we've
been helping but like we helped without
you asking we'll help if you ask to you
let me know music in the vlog like if
you want to like like I might number one
recommendation the same thing you're
doing with kids in school go hard after
YouTube vloggers and get your music in
their [ __ ] vlogs
it's the number one you get Jake and
Paul to put in using saw or Casey or and
by the way those are the ones just I
know them and they're big there's [ __ ]
a hundred thousand bloggers I'll put
them on the way and the way I'm doing
that I'm already doing it the right way
notice exactly first I put into place
cuz it's authentic then now I said the
reason he's like listen guy just kicked
out is it's looking to give me millions
of dollars and I'm gonna kick him out
because I want to get a sense of you cuz
then if I'm like with it like from a
good spirits standpoint then it's just
gonna make us want to do it more like as
soon as I like that one story the
speaker thing I'm like cool good now I
just have to do like this is very real
to me I just want to make sure kids are
good kids like I you know I mean like I
don't need you punching girls or like
doing dumb [ __ ] but once once I
understand the person is good and smart
I'll [ __ ] by the way it's selfish I'll
[ __ ] give give give give give because
that means you're gonna win and one day
when you're in front of 90,000 [ __ ]
people in London they be like big shout
out to my homie Gary Vee put me on first
like this I'm not I'm not Mother Teresa
I'm just smart and and by the way even
if you don't I don't have that gear
where I'm like [ __ ] we put you know this
about me we put them on why aren't they
doing really I have no expectation of
others I just do the right never cuz I'm
gonna get cuz you know this I'm gonna
get mine anyway I don't need you so I
don't need anything from nobody I'm
doing it and a four out of every nine do
the right thing well four is better than
zero that's the way to do it that's how
you do it you understand
good man yeah listen listen listen
you're gonna learn cuz you're gonna win
you know people have different
interpretations of what help is it isn't
people Mehta three months and think like
you know like you know you know what I
mean you're gonna feel that but the key
is as long as you're judging yourself
and you're you know you're doing the
right thing you'll be set
collaborations in your music to not not
up but wide let me explain not sitting
here be like oh [ __ ] we got to do
something with Gucci Mane or 21 savage
or something like that
post one on No Ken well that's where I'm
going
are there people in country or pop or
jazz that are coming up like you to that
you just like their flavor or I thought
logic did it right like or just in
culture with [ __ ] auto-tune even Boyd
could sound good like one if somebody's
just winning in life baby Arielle just
put out music like I don't know it just
feels like almost anybody can get in the
game in certain ways with the technology
manses in post-production so just being
smart you know like like Russell
Westbrook - like some girl that's got 19
million followers on on snap you know
what I mean
no but that's just an example yeah but I
love that you asked that question well
this is our big strategy we think what's
going on Latin America is real as [ __ ]
like you know it's very clear that
American kids now don't give a [ __ ] that
they don't understand what the words are
saying
[Music]
can I give you a good piece of advice be
patient
that's the only thing that that's your
kryptonite right now you got you clearly
had your [ __ ] together the only thing
that's gonna [ __ ] you up is cuz you know
it's gonna happen you can feel it and
sometimes youngsters are just like [ __ ]
why hasn't it happened like 13 months
from now like happen like that song that
completely changed [ __ ] and then they
start doing short cuts signing with
somebody dumb doing the collab with
somebody dumb talking about something
they don't believe in just cuz they
think it will make a song popular they
deviate hundred percent but when you got
real talent and you're on the cusp
always but what happened you the reason
you're at this spot is cuz you're living
that life just from an old man's
standpoint this next chapter is the most
important one this is the one that
decides everything it's easy to stay
down when there's nothing to go up to
but when you're on the cusp that's it's
what I do it's hard like I'm [ __ ] by
one but I'm trying to win the whole
[ __ ] thing so I'm just eating [ __ ]
still
[Music]
[Music]
I came on you you hit on me a shame all
those try to run that game on you hit on
me